y si de repente nos revelarán que es
falso o al menos está bastante bastante
sesgado prácticamente todo
lo que nos dicen las diferentes
instituciones como en la cooperación
internacional y sobre ella en los medios
de comunicación en la ciencia y en el
arte en la publicidad el marketing en lo
que nos venden y compramos lo que
consumimos y nuestro modo de consumir
es falso prácticamente todo lo que nos
dicen acerca de lo que es y cómo es el
mundo la vida la comida nuestros cuerpos
nuestras mentes incluso nuestros deseos
nuestros sueños nuestros gustos la
belleza
nuestras aspiraciones
y también las de los otros
pero quiénes son los otros
y quiénes somos
nosotros
pero más aún si nos revelarán que todo
lo que los medios las instituciones la
ciencia nos han inculcado y grabado que
somos y que de hecho estamos siendo nos
convierte en activas piezas diminutas de
un gran puzzle
un puzle que dibuja desigualdad
injusticias pobreza hambrunas guerras
genocidios ecología y dios feminicidios
epistem ici dios y jerarquías a nivel
global que catalogan a las personas en
humanos y en sus humanos
y esclavización subalternización
destrucción de todo tipo a escala global
e histórica
voy a pediros que penséis en una imagen
étnica
seguramente os viene a la cabeza esto
o quizás esto no un look étnico no muy
de moda pero apuesto a que es imposible
y que levante la mano a alguien en la
sala si alguien ha pensado en
un hombre blanco con vestimenta típica
de su cultura local y concreta
porque nos han contado que lo normal el
objetivo lo deslocalizado lo
descontextualizado es una sola forma de
ser en el mundo la euro norteamericana
la occidental o céntrica y la cristiano
céntrica por eso cuando hacía mi
investigación en marruecos entrevistando
un cooperante español
pudo decirme tuvo la posibilidad de
decirme que dejaron de financiar una
asociación local marroquí porque
descubrieron que eran islamistas y
llegaron a esta conclusión porque vieron
que en las clases de costura a las
mujeres no les enseñaban según palabras
del propio cooperante hacer ropa normal
sino sílabas más rock jazz
las feministas norteamericanas que
hicieron campaña para concienciar a la
población de la terrible situación de
las mujeres afganas y de la imperiosa
necesidad de liberar las ellas y el
resto del mundo estaban plenamente
convencidos de la bondad y de la
superioridad moral y ética de su campaña
y de su misión
pero la realidad es que esas pobres
mujeres afganas vivían en la situación
en la que vivían por una larga historia
de colonización y de expoliación y
concretamente en ese momento al apoyo
logístico y armamentístico de la
administración estadounidense a sus
queridos amigos los talibanes para que
lucharán contra la urss
lo cierto es que la campaña de la famosa
influencia ante asociación feminista
abrió el camino y proporcionó la
coartada para la liberación americana de
las mujeres afganas una liberación made
in way bombardeando las violándolas
asesinando las y convirtiendo a
afganistán en el primer narcoestado a
nivel internacional
estamos
todas todas y todos en una gran cárcel
al interior aparece todo muy coherente e
incluso bonito todas y todos queremos
ser modernos queremos desarrollarnos
queremos ser progresistas queremos ser
feministas queremos ser
pero nadie o prácticamente nadie o muy
pocas personas son conscientes del
significado que trasciende a todos y
cada uno de los conceptos que utilizamos
dentro de esta gran cárcel
esta cárcel a través de conceptos como
el de civilización como el de
liberalización secularización
religión desarrollo feminismo
democratización va a producir normalidad
sujetos tradiciones estéticas culturas
sabores olores
y que van a aparecer como normales como
aceptables con posibilidad de ser de
reproducirse de existir y de vivir
esta producción de normalidad sin
embargo va a implicar un ejercicio
activo pero invisible y muy complejo de
producción de anormalidad de excepción
de rareza de zonas de no ser zonas
recluidas al silencio a la invisibilidad
y en un espacio donde nos llegan ni los
derechos ni la legislación
zonas donde no está permitido ni ser ni
existir estoy hablando de una cárcel
epistemológico existencial
espacio-temporal y estética que nos va a
imponer quien puede hablar como se puede
hablar y sobre qué temas es posible
hablar
las personas provenientes del corazón
del imperio tienen la competencia
necesaria para teorizar sin importar el
lugar físico epistemológico o cultural
porque de hecho sin civilizar a este
lugar local donde están es un prejuicio
que está anclado en la distribución
ideológica del conocimiento en las
ciencias sociales y también a la
organización geopolítica del primero
segundo y tercer mundo como se puede
hablar
es en qué términos es posible hacerla el
sistema mundo moderno colonial esto es
el sistema la dictadura global que nos
gobierna a todos que impone la dictadura
de una tercera parte de la humanidad
sobre dos terceras partes de la
humanidad e instituye la sustracción y
transferencias sistemáticas de los
bienes culturales espirituales humanos
epistémicos etcétera de esas dos
terceras partes de la humanidad hacia
una tercera parte de la humanidad para
su beneficio y que está anclado en el
sistema capitalista global en la idea de
raza y el sistema de sexo y género va a
determinar cuáles son los conceptos y
significantes que pueden ser utilizados
los conceptos con los que se puede
hablar con los que se puede ejercer la
enunciación y por lo tanto con los que
se va a construir y se está construyendo
la realidad por lo que dichos conceptos
se van a convertir en una medida de la
realidad solo y exclusivamente desde la
anunciación en y desde esta realidad es
que va a ser posible tener voz esto es
la posibilidad de ser sujeto y de tener
agencia sobre qué temas se puede hablar
o desde dónde enfocar los temas de
estudio y observación
es el punto de vista desde el cual se
aborda el estudio de las cosas que se
convierte en una radio en una
herramienta que va a restringir el
conocimiento y que de hecho lo va a
reestructurar y lo va a reinventar en la
invención del tercer mundo arturo
escobar nos relata como en 1949 el
presidente truman en su discurso de
investidura no solamente va a dar
entrada a la nueva era del desarrollo y
va a cerrar la era colonial donde
existían los discursos de las colonias
las metrópolis sino que nos relata como
en este discurso de golpe y porrazo 2000
millones de personas en el mundo se van
a convertir en seres subdesarrollados
se van a acabar los discursos de
metrópoli colonia de antaño pero van a
aparecer nuevos discursos como los de
desarrollados y subdesarrollados que van
a seguir reproduciendo las mismas
estructuras y jerarquías de dominación
van a cambiar las formas pero vamos a
seguir con las mismas estructuras en
1970 van a surgir los discursos de lo
que primero se va a llamar mujeres y
desarrollo y posteriormente género y
desarrollo y sandra talpa de mohanty una
de las madres de los llamados feminismos
post coloniales nos va a hablar de cómo
va a surgir con el nuevo enfoque de
género y es con el enfoque de mujeres y
desarrollo y luego género y desarrollo
esa llamada mujer del tercer mundo esa
otra por antonomasia que va a ser una
mujer producto típica y simplificada en
la imagen de una mujer pobre analfabeta
sexualmente reprimida oprimida sin
capacidad de resistencia etcétera
el salvaje en el espejo tiene todas las
características del que nosotras y
nosotros como occidentales no somos
whiteside también nos va a hablar del
orientalismo como un discurso como una
estructura de poder que va a dibujar
nuestro otro extremo a la vez que
simultáneamente está dibujando quién es
occidente occidente es todo lo que
oriente no es es pobre oriente
subdesarrollado es reprimido es
antidemocrático es terrorista no
pero y sí
esforzarnos en abrir nuestras
consciencias hasta nuestro lugar en el
mundo y su significado aunque sea una
tarea realmente muy difícil pero puede
transformar radicalmente este mundo
ahora quién es la mujer musulmana o
quiénes son las mujeres musulmanas si
preguntamos por ahí fuera vamos a
encontrar estas respuestas la esclava
del sultán swat quemada viva vendidas
casada a la fuerza deshonrado
danza del vientre del clon
imágenes como esta como cuando por
ejemplo un profesor cuando empecé los
estudios de doctorado en teoría política
me preguntó que para que una mujer
musulmana conejilla quería hacer una
tesis doctoral
esto que me encontré en el campus de la
autònoma del día internacional de la
mujer como símbolo universal de la
opresión femenina
pero nosotras las mujeres musulmanas no
necesitamos hacer esta pregunta porque
nosotras somos mujeres musulmanas y
sabemos muy bien lo deberíamos saber
perfectamente quiénes somos nosotros
necesitamos hacer otra pregunta
debemos dar la vuelta a los papeles
asignados y esta vez hagamos nosotras
las preguntas quién como por qué y para
qué
se pregunta quién es la mujer musulmana
quién por qué y para qué da estas
respuestas tan famosas ya que nos
caricaturizan y nos convierten en un
objeto de estudio e intervención sobre
el cual todo el mundo tiene derecho a
opinar ya decidir pero nosotras mismas
nos han convertido en la figura de una
mujer sumisa analfabeta pobre y
retrógrada pero esta vez nosotras no
sólo exigimos hacer las preguntas y
cuestionar de hecho sino que también
vamos a dar las respuestas
nosotras en plural
formamos parte de una población mundial
de más de 1500 millones de musulmanes
somos diversas somos heterogéneas somos
fuertes resistentes y luchadoras y
rompemos todos los esquemas es más somos
lo mejor de las diferentes sociedades
pero especialmente aquí en europa
creo que somos la mejor oportunidad para
liberar estas sociedades oprimidas y
subyugadas por sus cegueras racistas
supremacistas y coloniales el mayor
favor y la mejor contribución que
podemos hacer a nuestras sociedades aquí
es la de descolonizar europa el de abrir
las conciencias hacia formas de vida
respetuosas con la naturaleza y con
todos los seres humanos y sus inherentes
diferencias abrir las conciencias hacia
la devastación que supone el capitalismo
y su otra cara oculta el racismo el
clasismo el machismo la colonialidad
debemos dejar de repetir
el tan exigido ejercicio de
autoflagelación del no somos terroristas
y las demostraciones obligatorias de
diferentes niveles de progresismo de
uruguay ismo de modernidad cada vez que
nos acusan de terroristas de
oscurantistas de retrasados porque esto
se parece bastante al
al elefante azul no piensas en un
elefante azul y automáticamente se
aparece en la mente un elefante azul las
primeras víctimas
del terrorismo global son musulmanes
tanto a nivel
de números de cifras como a nivel moral
y mediático os imagináis que salgamos
los musulmanes después de los atentados
de north él anda
exigiría pedir a cualquiera que vemos
por la calle que no sea musulmán que sea
cristiano que se disculpe y que se dé
explicaciones por los atentados
terroristas supremacistas que sucedieron
ridículo como mínimo suena
y consciencia significa consciencia de
nuestro contexto global histórico
geopolítico y geoeconómico y cómo se
imbrica esto con nuestros discursos
nuestros deseos nuestras percepciones y
estilos de vida y también nuestro estilo
de consumir significa tener claro que el
colonialismo no es algo del pasado que
terminó con la pseudo independencias de
los países colonizados y empobrecidos y
significa también tomar la decisión de
deconstruir nos y de saber realmente en
qué y de qué lado estamos y a quién o
qué servimos significa tener que está
consciencia de que los discursos no son
inocentes
los discursos pueden matar los discursos
matan y pueden implicar aniquilación
material y física los discursos de vox
por ejemplo sobre la inquisición sobre
la reconquista sobre las mujeres y sobre
el enemigo de todo y de todos que
constituye alistan significan más bombas
significa
apoyo a las dictaduras que nos matan y
nos asfixian los países de mayoría de
población árabe y musulmana significa
más gente muriendo en las fronteras
significa más precariedad dentro de las
fronteras europeas y significa más
muerte
para acabar
hablemos de dos conceptos islámicos
quiero hablar desde el lugar desde el
que se nos impone el silencio y la
imposibilidad de hablar
y ello creo que constituye un ejercicio
fuertemente transgresor quiero hablar
del concepto del software del concepto
sistémico del software
la perseverancia la determinación y la
paciencia en la lucha contra las
injusticias y quiero hablar del concepto
de torrid la unicidad de al lado que nos
enseña que no hay un otro separado de
nosotros
que los otros no son la anulación de
nuestro ser la negación o la antítesis
de lo que somos como la concepción
occidental y que por ello se justifica
su aniquilación con el toro hit sin
embargo los otros son la más absoluta
afirmación y confirmación del mismo de
nosotros que tú que yo la naturaleza y
todos los seres vivos todo y todos
formamos parte de la vida formamos parte
de lo mismo y que por lo tanto nos
construimos y crecemos conjunta y
mutuamente dejemos entonces de hablar en
los términos en los que quieren que
hablemos y de pensar como quiere el
sistema que pensemos como condición
urgente y necesaria para abrir las
posibilidades de transformar el mundo en
un lugar más justo
y
más igualitario gracias
[Aplausos]